I'm Joe Biden this is the wired
auto-complete interview I'm about to do
have you ever googled yourself before no
I try not to there's car here is Joe
Biden a Democrat a Republican
what a silly question man what else
would you be by the Democrat I'd have to
change my name if I weren't a Democrat
my grandfather friend he would come back
from his grave all right is Joe Biden
running for president yes I am I'm
running for president is Joe Biden going
to win as my grandfather say is the
grace of God the good will of the
neighbors and the creek not rising yes
I'm gonna win is Joe Biden a billionaire
unfortunately I'm not okay is Joe Biden
religious I do not proselytize but I'm a
practicing Catholic yes is Joe Biden
Irish absolutely my mom side 100% Irish
my dad side half Irish we don't admit to
the other part his Joe Biden and parks
and recs
yes I wasn't Parks and Rec as long as I
didn't have to do anything other than
play myself I said I'd do it and a lot
of good people I miss Joe Biden
left-handed no that's why I'm I have
trouble pulling these off of my left
hand is Joe Biden a vegan no Joe Biden's
not a vegan although my wife is pushing
me most of the meals I eat quite frankly
don't add me a lot of chicken fair
amount of fish I'm big on ice cream and
that puts me in real trouble you know
what I mean so after all these years
it's very disappointing to be known for
two things my ray-bans and ice cream was
pretty dull okay
does Joe Biden have a brother I lucky I
have two younger brothers I'm the oldest
of three and I've got a sister who's the
love of my life does Joe Biden have a
dog I had two dogs I have two German
Shepherds one I got when I got named
vice president on States by Barack it
was bribery on the part of my family
said if you agree we'll get you a dog
again so I have a dog named Champy's
getting be an old guy and to keep him
young we went out and got another dog
from the rescue center
and his name is major is Joe Biden
dental law degree yes I do I have a law
degree from Syracuse University I
practiced law for a while here in
Delaware the job I'd never serve in the
military no I haven't but we're a
military family my son Beau served in
the military passed away he spent a year
in Iraq won the Bronze Star q speaker
Service Medal and a number of other
commendations the job I'd never have a
job yeah I've had a job I used to be a
lifeguard for years and when I ran for
the United States Senate they said well
why do you want a 29 year old guys only
been a lifeguard well the truth was I
was a practicing lawyer I've been a
public defender and I had my own small
law firm well I got an elected when I
was 29 and then I had another job
although I guess people don't consider
being a senator a job but that was my
other job did I go to college yes I did
go to college I went to the University
of Delaware and I enjoyed it's a great
school as my sister went and my brothers
as well it had two majors I majored in
history and political science and had a
minor in English the Joe Biden used to
be a Republican no never never never but
I tell you what it did happen when I
came back to Delaware from law school my
city was occupied by the National Guard
because of the fact that dr. King had
been assassinated the Democratic Party
at the time was much more conservative
the Republican Party so I couldn't bring
myself to register as a Republican
because I wasn't big on Richard Nixon
and I registered as an independent but
shortly thereafter I helped change the
Democratic Party to be a mainstream
Democratic party was a fairly
conservative party when I first got back
Ken Joe Biden so it'd be good play
sports I told my son when I died I
wanted only for words
father son brother athlete I was a
pretty good athlete in high school
played a little bit in college played
football and baseball and a couple
leagues when I got out of school yes I
love sports
did Joe Biden eat ice cream well some
people think that's all I do is you guys
you know my mom when my dad passed away
she moved in with us reluctantly because
she wanted her independence and I'd stop
and see her before I go upstairs and my
my wife would say you've been with your
mother I can smell ice cream and you
ready the point is I love ice cream
always have my favorite by the way is
chocolate chip can Joe Biden yell well I
don't yell very much I can yell when I'm
cheering for my kids my granddaughters
they're good athletes but that's about
it was Joe Biden a vice president yes I
was I served with a great guy Barack
Obama's one of the great honors of my
life is a man a significant integrity
and I one of the best things ever did
was Joe Biden fraternity no I never
joined a fraternity I was Joe Biden an
actor you can tell by this know where
Joe Biden's not an actor I'm not very
good at playing anything but myself oh I
used to be a very bad stutterer when I
was a kid and all through high school
that wasn't the reason I wasn't an actor
but I I've always felt self-conscious
about trying to be something that I
wasn't and that actually requires you to
be able to do that okay what is Joe
Biden's immigration policy keep families
together
immigration built this country we're all
with the exception of the original sin
of slavery are all immigrants the reason
why we're the great country we are we've
been able to cherry-pick the best of
every culture in the world for someone
to come here like my
great-great-grandfather getting on a
coffin ship in the Irish Sea back in
1848 it took courage it took optimism it
took determination that's why were who
we are we're a nation of immigrants I'm
proud of it what is Joe Biden's plan
from proving the economy you know there
used to be a basic bargain in America if
you contribute to the well-being of the
operation you work for you got to share
in the benefits that's changed in the
last 20 years because of corporate greed
because of a range of other things and
because of pizza clea now in this
administration the way in which it
doesn't take care of people who bust
their neck my dad used to say everyone
everyone is entitled to be treated with
dignity and
how can you have dignity if you're
working 40 hours a week and you can't
afford health care you can't afford to
take care of your children you can't
afford housing that's the reason I'm
running for president because I'm gonna
change that we're gonna rebuild the
middle class and this time bring
everybody along what is Joe Biden's view
in education my wife Jill has a great
expression she's a doctor of Education
and she's been a teacher for years and
she'd say any country that out-educates
us will out-compete us and so that's why
I strongly believe we should have both
ends of the spectrum changes so that
every child 3 4 & 5 years old can go to
school school not daycare school and all
the studies show that increases
exponentially their chance of success at
the other end of it we should have free
Community College free college for four
years of college of a State University
if you come from a family making less
than $125,000 and we should be invested
in an apprenticeships across the board
we can do anything when we put our minds
to it what is Joe Biden saying about
impeachment obviously the president
didn't learn anything from being
impeached and not convicted the reason
he got impeach was he went to another
country that's them to get involved in
our political process which is an
impeachable offense he got impeached but
then Republican Senate refused even
though some acknowledged he did what he
said that it didn't warrant being kicked
out of office we are really not
following the law very well these days
what Joe Biden stance on gun control
number one assault weapons are weapons
of death they have no rationale for
being owned by individuals on the street
they should be outlawed they were
eliminated they came back at a 10-year
elimination of them from the very
beginning you weren't allowed to have
certain weapons you weren't allowed to
own a cannon during the Revolutionary
War as an individual
anybody think you should be able to go
out and have a machine gun these days
and the answer is no we have a rational
policy no amendment to the Constitution
is absolute secondly everyone should
have a universal background check in
order to determine whether they're
capable of owning a weapon whether they
should own a weapon okay why is Joe
Biden running for president I'm
for president for three reasons one to
restore the soul of this country
this president started off dividing us
based on race religion ethnicity one of
the reasons I decided to run this time I
had planned on it was what happened in
Charlottesville
when those folks came out of the woods
carrying torches carrying swastikas and
then when a young woman was killed he
was asked to comment and he said the
refined people on both sides no
president has ever said anything like
that we have to restore the soul this
country we the people we hold these
truths to be self-evident he's walked
away from that the second reason I'm
running and restore the backbone of this
country the middle class and this time
bring everybody along black/white all
colors all backgrounds men women gay
straight everyone everyone deserves a
shot and the third reason I'm running is
to unite the country this is not who we
are
we're better than this we're better than
what we're having what we have now and
the American people I think know that
why is Joe Biden a good candidate well I
always said when I won the first time as
a kid running for the Senate of 29
people would come along and say what's
the secret like you had to be a secret
if I want at that age I'd say look if
you're gonna run for office figure out
what you're willing to lose over say
what you mean mean what you say and
don't rationalize tell the truth and let
the cards fall where they may
why would you want the job unless you
did that why is Joe Biden a Democrat
because we start off with the
proposition that anybody given a half a
chances has the capacity to do anything
but they need a chance it's all about
having a chance my dad used to say Joey
I don't expect the government to solve
my problems but I expect him to
understand my problems give me a
fighting chance no guarantees a lot of
people have not had much of a fighting
chance and you're seeing that in this
pandemic look at the people carrying us
on their backs those people making seven
eight bucks an hour those people in the
grocery store stacking product those
people driving the trucks those people
were out there as nurse's aides those
people are putting on garbage bags
because they didn't have the protective
equipment I hope that the blinders have
been taken off here the very people
showing up to help you bury people saved
your lives
people are working for you are people
who in fact are of all backgrounds all
colors and all all interest so we got a
united country thank you